nobody take this title before
with muslim muslims like more than
billion people you know
when come ramadan this is everything for
me i don't think about fight
because i believe in one god this is my
religion
religion for me number one sport is not
for me number one
for all the khabib nurmagomedov fans
this is a denizen
of the russian republic of dagestan
for all the mma fans he's an undefeated
mma
fighter and i'm going to go ahead and
discuss
some peculiar idiosyncrasies you've seen
him do it some things he's done
some things he said during some of his
fights so you can appreciate i'm sure
you will appreciate when you can
connect it to something you're familiar
with
the winner by submission due to kimura
[Music]
now let's start off with what he's doing
here this is not just particular to him
you'll see many people who
want to keep it humble and who are
thankful and grateful they point
up pointing up to the one up above up
above the creation
up above the heavens and the universe
the one who created this whole universe
the galaxies the seven seas everything
in this
world isn't he not worthy of all praise
and things and that's what he's doing
because people become very arrogant and
this is something we have to be very
very careful of and we can all take a
lesson from this to keep it humble
to keep it humble you cannot go wrong
with keeping it humble arrogance will
get you lost
we'll lose your friends who likes to be
around arrogant people
and at the end failure failure at the
end
[Music]
why is he putting his face on the ground
what's he doing kissing the ground
but let me connect it because the point
was if i can if we can connect it to
something that you are familiar with
someone
who you're familiar with you're probably
going to appreciate it a lot more
you might even start doing it and
if something works if it's going to help
improve your life why not give it a try
and check this out you know jesus we
know jesus i mean did you know
muslims love jesus there's this fighter
here if anyone knows who he is he's
wearing
he's another mixed martial arts fighter
he's got a
he's got a shirt on talking about
how muslims love jesus did you know that
so if you're a
khabib fan you've learned something
already and you'll see that muslims they
have a deep
reverence and love for jesus as a mighty
messenger who was sent just like abraham
knowing all the
other messengers calling people to
connect with the one
who gave us these abilities these gifts
in life
like khabib was given some very talented
athlete
and and and he's acknowledging that this
is from the creator
and now again he's taking it a step
further
and just like jesus and related to
someone you know jesus
in the gospel of matthew 26 39 it says
that he went and he went a little
further
and he fell on his face and prayed to
god
isn't that amazing this is something
that habib doing
not only him but muslims 1.7 billion
human beings and muslim is simply one
who surrenders who submits themselves
not to a man not to a woman not to money
not to fame not to anything
or anyone but to the creator up above
isn't that beautiful
you learned something already he's doing
what all the prophets of god did
so it shouldn't be next time you see him
do that next time you're a fan of khabib
and you see you see him fighting at the
end
and if he wins god willing and he
prostrate he puts his head on the floor
you can connect it now you watch this
you say oh he's doing what jesus did
he's giving praise and thanks
keeping it humble excuse me guys
alhamdulillah now let's move on to the
next thing what he said he says some
some words now sometimes when we hear
something in another language we can't
appreciate it
excuse me guys alhamdulillah i want to
say
something he says alhamdulillah
[Applause]
what does that mean why is he saying
something in
another language in arabic now i want to
connect this
again back to the one i'm sure many
christians who love
jesus people who aren't even maybe
christian but they heard jesus they have
they have a connection to him do you
know that jesus he called on the creator
if you ever watched the
the passion of christ i'll take hello
[Music]
in arabic it's just allah this is the
creator we're talking about
and he is saying alhamdulillah
alhamdulillah
everything god gave me so again he's
keeping
it humble if anything we could take away
from this video is is
is that quality of keeping it humble we
got too much
we're all susceptible to it ego the ego
can take over and you become very
arrogant who likes to be around arrogant
people
keeping it humble again he's saying
alhamdulillah it's just like saying
thank you god
everything's god gave me very simple now
you're going to preach can you
appreciate that
let's go on to the next thing
and the last but not the least allahu
akbar do you hear him saying it
allah what does it mean
is it some war cried jihad they're
coming to get us
how ridiculous does that sound but
that's what some people think
do you know that over
60 000 books in a span of a hundred
years have been written against
islam according to the times magazine
article published in 1979
april 16th i believe it was and that the
islamophobia industry is a
250 million dollar annual business
so you know probably the information you
got
the book you read false propaganda
fear-mongering
and the hate-mongers they're making
money bashing throwing dirt on islam so
allahu akbar is not a war
cry it's simply allah
god is greater greater than that money
that dollar that job that woman
everything that you can imagine god
almighty the creator allah is greater
than this
and again going back to keeping it
humble
always thanking the one who gave you the
abilities
to win that championship to get up in
the morning
to eat the wonderful food to breathe
this
air you don't got to go to walmart to
get it it's free
so you say god almighty is great it's
like saying hallelujah
hallelujah you've heard that allah
allahu akbar god almighty is the
greatest
so that's what khabib is saying i'll
help you to
familiarize yourself with some of the
things that he does what muslims do in
general because khabib is a muslim one
who has consciously submitted to the
creator of the heavens and the earth
and some of those stereotypes that one
might have in the back of his head
he's heard this term allahu akbar now if
you were
to equate because islam is a beautiful
way of life calling you have peace
with the creator peace within yourself
so you can have that peace that money
can't buy and you have peace with
humanity if you were to
take all the isis and the boko haram and
al-qaeda which
which didn't even exist a decade ago
it's because all of these wars is that
hate war hate violence terrorism
cycle that we gotta stop innocent blood
here
there everywhere is human life we gotta
condemn one
condemn all and when you have any large
group of people
you're gonna have radicals you're going
to have extremists but we also have to
see
what's the root of all this and islam is
not the root my friends
no islam brings that peace and happiness
into one's life and when someone has
peace and happiness
he's not trying to blow nobody up
especially himself or innocent people
but you have these things going on but
this is a geopolitical thing and if you
were to add up all of these groups
this is just a side note i'm going out
for an atanja isis boko haram and all
these groups i'm sure you've heard and
people
out there associate because some people
are going to watch this video they're
going to think you know
again those those because of the effect
of the islamophobia machine so take all
these
radical groups compare that to the over
1.7 billion muslims
all over the globe it would only equate
to
if you have this small fringe element to
the 1.7 billion last time i checked it
would be like 0.006
it's like taking the kkk lords the
resistance army
or some of these these secular atheists
grooves pkk
and all all the time tigers all of these
these these
these terrorist groups and now you try
to
pump them up put them up as if they're
exemplary
representatives of christianity of
secularism
of atheism whatever ism that wouldn't be
fair there wouldn't be rights you can't
take a radical fringe element and try to
pump them up
as if they represent islam they don't
they don't represent habib
they don't represent me they don't
represent the over 1.7 billion muslims
who again are trying to keep it humble
keep it simple
live a peaceful life like everyone else
people who have connected with muslims
john dutcher will straight out tell you
what he thought of muslims
i actually hated muslims the women with
their headdress on you know i just would
sneer at them
dutcher was surrounded by the people he
loathed
but muslims moving in moved him
it took this to yeah to wake me
you know wake me up yeah a change of
heart for the man who didn't realize
he had such a big heart you know
what struck me the most honestly was
when i took a minute to actually
talk to some of the muslim people to
find out you know
they are just like me and i am
uneducated on their religion
you know i could easily make as many
mistake judgment calls as any other
person out there
but when i took a second to sit down and
listen to them and um
actually enter their mosque and go on
and watch some of their prayers it was a
beautiful thing and they answered some
of my questions that i had
and i just feel that maybe that that's
something that they they should do too
for the people
a lot of us are uneducated you know
educate us on your religion
let us know that not everybody's a bad
bad person